[Music]
welcome to this video where we'll
discuss the concept of fleets we'll go
over what fleets are and why you may
want to work with fleets as you manage
your container workloads before you
continue you should be familiar with
basic kubernetes concepts like
clusters now your cluster environment
may contain just a single kubernetes
cluster or you may choose to have
multiple clusters there are many reasons
why you may choose to deploy multiple
clusters for example you may want to
separate staging from production
environments or you may want to have
clusters in different regions and so on
and maybe you have these clusters in
Google cloud or across multiple Cloud
providers on premises or a combination
of all of these it can get pretty
complex to manage these multicluster
deployments across multiple
environments that's where fleets come in
with Fleet Lees you can logically group
kubernetes clusters so you can manage
your containerized workloads from a
group level instead of an individual
cluster level for example you can apply
a common set of policies to multiple
clusters at once and ensure your
kubernetes clusters and workloads are
running in a secure and compliant manner
when you're creating a fleet the first
thing you'll want to consider is
grouping how do you decide which
clusters will be grouped together as
part of a fleet let's take an example of
an organization with multiple lines of
business if these departments are
managed separately they may rarely
communicate with each other in this case
it might make sense to have a separate
Fleet for each line of business how you
decide to group clusters as part of a
fleet will depend on your specific
organizational needs you'll want to
consider whether the Clusters are
related to one another if they are in
the same production environment for
example then they should be managed
together in a fleet
as we mentioned earlier you also want to
consider management clusters that are
managed together benefit the most from
being grouped together managing your
clusters with fleets helps your
organization efficiently manage
infrastructure and workloads and ensures
consistent secure operations across all
environments for more information on
fleets check out this
[Music]
documentation